Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an action-comedy
film called “The Shaolin Boy.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
Lee is a six-year-old monk studying in the
Shaolin Monastery.
He has lived in the monastery and trained
in martial arts his entire life.
At the beginning of the movie, Lee walks into
the monastery and apologizes to his seniors
for what he is about to do.
He has to showcase his skills by fighting
them.
Without him releasing, a monk attacks him
from the side.
Lee immediately dodges, even though the attack
took him by surprise.
The monk manages to throw Lee to the wall
but he bounces right back and continues to
fight.
He showers the monk with several kicks midair,
displaying his skills.
Moments later, the first monk is defeated
when Lee restrains him with a woven bamboo
basket.
Following that, he is attacked by the second
monk armed with swords. Lee manages to disarm
his opponent, leaving him with no choice but
to accept defeat.
Then, he approaches the third and last monk.
Even when meditating, the monk senses Lee
coming towards him and uses a prayer bead
to perfectly hit the mirror in a way that
blinds Lee.
Then, in less than a second, the kid is picked
up and thrown to the ground.
The monk is about to win with the last blow
but Lee slides away and kicks him in the chest.
The two battle and in the end, Lee wins again.
He bows to the shrine and walks outside while
his opponents bow to him as a sign of respect.
The head monk tells Lee that he scored eighty-eight
out of a hundred in the test, which is better
than most students his age.
Lee is about to go to a new school in the
city as an exchange student.
During his stay there, he is supposed to live
with a family of three, fathered by a great
scientist who is close to the head monk.
After wishing farewell, the kid leaves for
the city, excited to meet new people.
In the following scene, we are introduced
to fifteen-year-old Feng, the chief of the
taekwondo club in his school.
He has a fourth-grader sister Shanshan, who
always cheers for her older brother and loves
him dearly.
The manager of the school Taekwondo club is
Lan.
She analyses Feng’s matches and gives him
a summary of what he could have done better.
Lan also seems to have a crush on him but
denies it when asked.
Lan’s brother Yu is a glutton who loves
to eat more than anything in the world.
The four of them live in the same neighborhood
and are pretty close to each other.
One afternoon, Lan is analyzing the previous
day’s Taekwondo match as always while her
brother Yu binges on chips and snacks.
The sibling’s father is a scientist named
Dr. Han.
Their mother died a few years ago after which,
Dr. Han has indulged himself in his work.
He is working on a special device that a group
of gangsters is interested in.
Dr. Han calls the kids to ask them how they
are doing.
Lan is annoyed because her father is never
home with them.
Dr. Han promises to return back as soon as
possible and tells them to open a gift box
that he has just sent to the house.
In reality, the box contains the special device
he has created that the gang is after.
As they are talking, Lee knocks on their door
and is received by Lan.
She gets busy welcoming him and doesn’t
notice that her father is being abducted on
the other side of the video call.
The leader of the gang, Larry, threatens Dr.
Han to hand them the important device.
Dr. Han, on the other hand, claims that there
is no such device.
What he has been working on is an AI technology
that will allow his kids to talk to an AI
with their mother’s voice.
The leader doesn’t believe him and holds
him hostage.
On checking the CCTV camera footage, he finds
out that the device has been shipped to his
home and received by his children.
Two of Larry’s henchmen, Sloppy and Fist
volunteer to retrieve the device no matter
what.
Until they get hold of it, Dr. Han will be
kept hostage.
Sloppy and Fist are excited because this is
their first job as gangsters.
They dress up in eccentric clothes as a disguise
and arrive in front of Lan’s house.
Sloppy tries to barge in when it gets dark
but Fist suggests they wait until the kids
leave for school the next day.
Meanwhile, Lee is getting accustomed to the
new environment.
He sees Lan watching a Taekwondo match on
TV and is fascinated by the sport.
Later, he tries to do his daily night-time
meditation while Yu plays a video game.
Both of them disturb each other and find it
hard to live together.
But soon, they play the video game together
and bond over it.
In her room, Lan opens that box sent by her
father and sees a panda keychain inside, what
she doesn’t know is that it also holds a
pen drive that the gang is looking for.
On pressing a button, the panda asks Lan to
set a voice-activated password.
She exclaims “what password” which is
set as the new password without her knowing.
On testing it further, she realizes that the
panda is an AI that has their mother’s voice.
The next morning, Lee gets ready for his first
day of school, alongside Yu and Lan.
Sloppy and Fist watch them from inside their
car, planning to break in right after they
are out of sight.
But just then, Sloppy notices that Lan has
hung the panda keychain in her bag.
They change plans and decide to steal it from
her.
On the way to school, the group meets Feng
and his sister Shanshan.
Lan introduces him to Lee.
As they're talking, Sloppy swiftly snatches
the keyring and walks away.
Lee notices this and does a high jump and
several backflips to get to him.
Feng is impressed to see that he is a skilled
fighter.
They both beat him up and get the panda but
Sloppy doesn’t give up.
He snatches it yet again, not learning his
lesson from the first time.
The kids soon surround him and trap him inside
a garbage bin before pushing him down the
road.
In the school, Lee is introduced to his classmates
who are amazed to see a child monk for the
first time.
They ask him questions like if he can ever
get married, and if he knows Kung Fu.
The teacher quiets them down and asks them
to wait for the gym period to see his Kung
Fu skills.
During the gym class, the coach informs them
of a fitness test that will be held next month.
The ones who do not pass the test will have
to repeat the class next year as well.
Yu is worried because he is out of shape and
can barely walk properly.
Their first task is to run a hundred meters.
A trained Lee completes two laps before his
classmates can complete even one.
Next, they are asked to do push-ups, one of
many specialties that Lee has.
He does more than a hundred while the other
kids can hardly do two.
To show his true capabilities, he even does
pushups with a single hand and then with his
body vertical.
Everyone cheers and praises him.
Then, it is time for them to do high jumps.
Elementary school high jumps are a piece of
cake for Lee.
However, Yu struggles and falls face down
on the platform.
Back in Dr. Han’s lab, the gangster Larry
has tied him to a chair and is hitting him
with golf balls.
To keep himself entertained, Dr. Han teaches
him new techniques at his own expense.
At night, Sloppy and Fist break into the house
looking for the panda. Lee sees them and hides
behind a stuffed toy to scare them.
He troubles the rookie gangsters but they
soon see him and try to fight him.
When Lan comes downstairs, the gangsters grab
the panda and run away.
Lee tells them what happened but the siblings
think he is joking.
In the following scene, Sloppy and Fist are
at the lab with golf balls in their mouths.
It turns out that they accidentally stole
a panda humidifier instead of the special
device.
Larry has to sell the said device to his clients
in three days which makes him impatient.
He uses Fist and Sloppy as golf tees to threaten
them to complete the task quicker.
The following day after school, the group
is watching Feng fight against an opponent.
Yu and Shanshan are talking about two ugly
girls in the back of the bleacher.
It turns out that the said girls are Sloppy
and Fist in disguise.
They eye the panda on Lan’s bag and wait
for the right time to retrieve it.
Just then, Lee challenges Feng to a match
and everyone goes to the front to watch it.
Behind them, the thugs try to take off the
panda from the bag but their wig gets stuck,
making them struggle.
As the intense fight continues, we see that
Feng and Lee match in skills.
It ends abruptly when both the participants
refuse to hit each other.
Just then everyone turns around and sees Sloppy
and Fist in their school girl dresses.
The kids attack the gangsters but the two
manage to flee with the panda after taking
a girl hostage.
The students go to the principal and call
the police who promise to do their best to
find them.
Lee blames himself for what happened because
if he hadn’t challenged Feng to a fight,
Lan wouldn’t be distracted.
The rest of the group makes him understand
that they do not blame him.
Larry finally gets the panda and uses the
pen drive inside it to open a program on a
computer.
However, it requires a password to be accessed.
Larry asks Dr. Han what the password is but
he refuses to tell them.
A couple of programmers try to break the code
but even after trying for an entire day, they
are not successful.
By the end of it, Larry starts to lose his
mind and has a mental breakdown.
Then, he sees Lan’s message on Dr. Han’s
phone and decides to use her to blackmail
him.
Lan has asked her father to come to her birthday
tomorrow.
Larry replies as Dr. Han and claims that he
will be there on time.
The next evening, Lan and her friends gather
at her house for the birthday party.
Meanwhile, Feng, Yu, Lee, and Shanshan have
gone to the market to get her presents.
Lan gets a message from her father saying
that he is outside.
However, on going out to check, she is abducted
and put inside a van.
At the same time, Lee and the group spot her
and follow the van on their bicycles.
They reach Dr. Han’s lab and start looking
for her.
Larry and his business partner are under stress
because they were supposed to close the deal
yesterday.
To make the process quicker, Larry puts a
knife to Lan’s face and asks her about the
password.
She in turn inquires “what password” and
it opens the program on the computer.
Outside, Sloppy and Fist are guarding the
place.
Lee and Feng attack them and knock them out
in no time.
However, they are soon confronted by Larry’s
right-hand man Bradley.
He is a fighter, hence, they struggle to defeat
him, even when teamed up.
Inside the lab, Larry and his partner are
about to seal the deal but just then, Yu arrives
and secretly frees his sister and father.
Lee also comes to their aid and helps them
fight the gangsters.
Amidst the chaos, Larry gets a hold of the
suitcase with the pen drive and runs outside.
He is stopped by Dr. Han, Yu, and Lan who
beat him up.
In the meantime, Lee joins Feng again to fight
against Bradley.
Initially, they struggle but they eventually
manage to defeat him.
At last, the police arrive at the scene and
save the day.
In the ending scene, we see the school’s
principal award Lee and Yu for their bravery.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.